[Musique]
un bon soir mardi 16 novembre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 tout de suite
les titres de l'actualité locale
l'inauguration cet après midi à la
verrière de la maison du projet pour
l'avenir du bois de l'étang son ambition
être un lieu de vie et d'échangés autour
de la rénovation urbaine du quartier qui
va largement se transformer dans les
prochaines années et nicolas dainville
maire de la commune est notre invité le
meeting de valérie pécresse hier au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines 900
personnes y ont assisté la candidate au
congrès des républicains est en campagne
dans le département où elle est élue et
puis de nouveaux espaces de travail et
de convivialité pour les étudiants la
mezzanine vauban a été inaugurée sur le
campus de guyancourt de l'université
versailles saint quentin a lieu composée
notamment d'un petit amphithéâtre ouvert
retour également dans cette édition sur
la soirée et des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés empêcher elle se dérouler ce
lundi à la commanderie en cours
[Musique]
la ville de la verrière inauguré cet
après-midi une maison du projet pour
l'avenir du bois de l'étang situé en
plein coeur du quartier ce nouveau lieu
a pour but de faciliter la concertation
avec les habitants au sujet de la
rénovation du quartier les précisions de
mathilde francon
la ville de la verrière a présenté ce
mardi 16 novembre sa nouvelle maison du
projet pour recueillir les idées et les
témoignages des habitants du quartier du
bois de l'étang au sujet du prochain
plan de renouvellement urbain on a
ouvert cette maison du projet pour
permettre aux habitants de s'exprimer de
manière libre sans pression à travers
les urnes à travers les permanences à
travers la consultation des plans du
projet le projet de renouvellement
urbain comprend la démolition de 212
logements la ville de la verrière a donc
fait appel à l'entreprise séquence pour
réaliser une enquête sociale auprès des
habitants du bois de l'étang qui sont
concernés par la démolition de leur
logement on a
74% des familles qui se sont déclarés
favorables au projet de renouvellement
urbain et plus encore 85% qui se sont
déclaré
favorable à un relogement ou charte
intercommunale a été signé par les 12
maires de l'agglomération
elle garantit à tous les habitants une
question prioritaire de leur dossier il
ya 72 % des familles qui souhaitent être
logés en dehors de la commune et c'est
vrai que comme on a cinq mille logements
sur saint quentin en yvelines et cent
mille logements en ile de france
voilà c'est vrai que c'est quand ça les
capacités de faire des propositions
correspondant aux soins et aux besoins
des familles depuis le lundi 18 octobre
les habitants peuvent donner leur avis
sur les futurs aménagements du quartier
du bois de l'étang comme les voiries la
végétation ou encore l'e commerce tout
reste à décider avec les habitants quel
commerce quel commerce on veut qu'elle
nouvelle maison de quartier qu'à l'école
quel service voilà tous ces détails là
qui sont extrêmement importants pour la
vie du quartier il faut lui décidé avec
les habitants nouvelle voirie nouvelle
école nouvelle maison de quartier se
plaint de renouvellement urbain est
chiffré à 70 7 millions d'euros il a
également pour objectif de doubler le
pont de lavilledieu pour ouvrir le
quartier va à l'extérieur
et avec moi par visioconférence nicolas
dainville bonsoir bonsoir mr de la
verrière alors on rappelle les
principales informations assure ce
renouvellement urbain du quartier du
bois de l'étang 106 116 logements avec
une réhabilitation
résidentialisation de 404 logement une
démolition de 212 logements et la
création d'un groupe scolaire avec aussi
une maison de quartier le désenclavement
du quartier c'est l'ambition affichée
par ce projet de rénovation urbaine on
vous a entendu dans le sujet d'hier et
bien cette maison du projet c'est aussi
donner l'opportunité à des habitants de
s'exprimer librement sans pression
pourquoi il fallait donner justement
cette opportunité aux habitants
et bien parce que beaucoup d'habitants
ont envie de participer à l'avenir de
leur quartier ils ont envie de donner
leurs propositions ils ont envie de
donner leur avis mais malheureusement on
a
un fait naître de pression beaucoup ont
peur de s'exprimer librement et je les
comprends et donc il faut effectivement
multiplier les espaces les moments où
ils peuvent s'exprimer de manière libre
et donc on a les yeux on en a des
adresses mails on a cette maison du
projet qui permet à chacun de venir
notamment avec des permanences pour
avoir des réponses à toutes leurs
questions ou pour pouvoir donner leur
avis voilà on voit ya beaucoup
d'habitants qui vient de le parler
qu'ils nous disent monsieur le maire on
on n'a pas envie de subir la pression la
peur parce qu'il ya parfois des menaces
parce qu'il ya parfois des intimidations
on a envie de vous dire ce qu'on a sur
le coeur et donc grâce à tous ces lieux
et tous ces outils ils peuvent vraiment
contribué à améliorer l'attractivité du
quartier pour les relire du quartier et
de la ville mais ce qu on se souvient en
juillet notamment d'une réunion publique
très tendue en présence du préfet des
yvelines jean jacques brot comment on
compose justement vous le dites avec
peut-être cesser pression pour ce projet
important à la verrière ce projet du
renouvellement du bois de l'étang
m'écouter une première étape qui est
très important c'est cette enquête
sociale enquête sociale qui a été mené
par un cabinet indépendant et juste
après ben autant que juste après la
réunion publique du 5 juillet que vous
avez bloqué et bien cette enquête
sociale sur les familles concernées par
une démolition il ya 80% des familles
qui ont répondu à l'enquêté sociale ce
qui est un chiffre très important
74 % d'entre elles sont favorables à
notre projet de renouvellement urbain
plus 80 % sont favorables à la
perspective du relogement et donc on a
une écrasante majorité de familles qui
veulent cet avenir qu'ils veulent ce
projet qui veulent se secoue de jeunesse
pour ce quartier qui en a bien besoin
parce qu'ils ont bien conscience que
malgré l'attachement qu'ils ont au
quartier certains il y habite depuis
très longtemps et bien on a un quartier
qui souffre d'un manque d'attractivité
qui a des pannes de structures avec des
canalisations vétustes des ascenseurs en
panne des pannes de mécanique sauvage de
voitures ventouses auquel on a du mal à
lutter durablement et donc tout l'enjeu
c'est d'améliorer l'accessibilité du
quartier pour les pompiers pour la
police pour les habitants d'améliorer la
mixité sociale avec une offre de
logement le plus diverses d'améliorer le
confort avec vraiment les canalisations
laissées anita les halls d'immeuble la
sécurisation des accès qui va être
lourdement améliorée et puis date de
données je vous dire un nouvel avenir
pour ce quartier qu'on aime mais qui en
a besoin pour les dix prochaines années
avec l'enfouissement des lignes haute
tension en parallèle le pont de la ville
du en parallèle aussi et tout cela c'est
essentiel et les habitants sont très
très nombreux à nous le dira mais voilà
malheureusement je dirais qu'on fait
face à à des groupes qui veulent saboter
le projet qui veulent le faire échouer
combien mais soyons répondu justement à
l enquête que vous évoquez combien de
personnes a écouté les 212 on a 2 112
familles concernées il ya cent
quatre-vingt dix-huit appartements
occupés et par lui ses 198 appartements
occupés on a 80 % de ces 198 belle
logements qui ont répondu à leur est
donc pour un projet on rappelle le coup
1 78 million d'euros estimés avec une
participation de plusieurs acteurs on
peut citer notamment le département des
yvelines 1,22 million d'euros ce qui
représente environ à peu près 28 % de ce
projet vous parliez aussi on en parlait
dans le sujet de cette charte
intercommunale pour le relogement
justement c'est une question centrale
aussi dans ce projet de renouvellement
urbain quand vont commencer justement
ces relogements c'est est évoquée pour
la fin de l'année ce qu'on est toujours
dans ce calendrier pour le début d'année
des relogements mais à écouter leurs
enquêtes sociales vient de se terminer
donc on en a eu 80 % des familles qui
ont répondu maintenant leur logement va
pouvoir commencer
séquence est en train de mettre en place
ses équipes chargées du relogement
l'intérieur est en train de s'organiser
puisque c'est une charte inédite entre
les douze communes de l'agglo il est
onze lier pour permettre aux personnes
relogées d'être en priorité relogées et
que le critère de leur souhait que leur
souhait vraiment soit le premier critère
pris en compte dans leur logement elles
ont exposé leurs souhaits beaucoup
souhaitent se quitter la ville
près de 80% de ceux qui ont répondu soit
quitter la verrière voilà et donc tout
cela se met en place et donc on va être
déjà des familles ont été relogées et
cela à s'intensifier dans les deux
prochaines années il ya une concertation
ça a été évoqué aussi qui a été lancé
depuis le 18 octobre elle se poursuit
jusqu'à dimanche ce 21 novembre où les
habitants 1 peuvent consulter et déjà le
dossier du projet donner leur avis avec
des urnes qui sont mises à disposition
dans plusieurs lieux de la commune il ya
aussi citons un deux réunions encore qui
doivent se dérouler une ce soir qui est
à 18h30 en mairie sur l'environnement le
cadre de vie une jeudi soir à 18h30 sur
la circulation le stationnement la
sécurité comment avais allez vous
utiliser justement les avis que vous
aller recueillir dans dans la suite de
ce projet qu'est ce qui reste à
déterminer justement eh bien écoutez
déjà c'est un projet qui dure depuis
sept ans et donc depuis sept ans il ya
eu beaucoup de réunions beaucoup d'avis
qui ont nourri ce projet on a maintenant
un cadre le cadre c'est l'anru alors
c'est contraignant ça impose un minimum
de démolition pour je dirais changer
durablement le quartier le rendre plus
ouvert plus accessible mais à
l'intérieur du cal tout reste à
construire avec les habitants
constructif qui souhaitent participer à
ce changement est donc tout reste à
décider ensemble quels services l'on
souhaite dans le quartier quel commerce
l'on veut quelle nouvelle école
puisqu'on aura une nouvelle école
moderne pour accueillir au mieux nos
enfants quelle nouvelle maison de
quartier quel type de réhabilitation
semble urgente pour les as du temps donc
tous ces détails si important reste à
construire avec les habitants
il ya des habitants qui tous les jours
nous écrivent qui tous les jours
participe par internet dans les
permanences dans nos rendez-vous dans
les urnes et qui donnent leur avis sur
les types de voirie qui souhaiteraient
voir sur les types de sécurité en termes
de sécurité routière sur les types
d'écoles pour accueillir et faire
réussir les enfants sur les types de
commerce voilà tout cela les habitants
participent et tous ceux qui participent
je peux vous dire c'est extrêmement
important puisque ça permet de de
finaliser le projet voilà intérieur du
cadre le cadre de l'anru mais à
l'intérieur la co-construction nous est
essentiel concertation lancée jusqu'au
21 novembre toutes les informations sur
le site internet de la derrière une
dernière question au début des travaux
fin 2022 pour pour ce projet
écoutez oui tout va se dérouler
effectivement dans les prochains mois on
va commencer par la réhabilitation
les réhabilitations des plus de 400
logements que vous évoquiez ensuite leur
logement se poursuivra dans les deux
trois prochaines années puis viendra les
travaux de l'école la nouvelle école
puis des voiries puis du pont de la
ville du en 2025 ce projet qui s'étalera
sur près de 10 ans mais 10 ans c'est ce
qui permettra de donner au quartier
nouvelle attractivité et un nouvel
avenir merci nicolas d'envié d'avoir été
avec nous
je le rappelle maire de la commune de la
verrière
[Musique]
la candidate au congrès les républicains
valérie pécresse en meeting c'était ce
lundi au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 900 personnes
présentes un rendez vous sur son
territoire des yvelines dans le cadre de
la campagne le reportage de nicolas
landry
[Musique]
c'est une étape à domicile de la
campagne de valérie pécresse devant 900
personnes au total la candidate au
congrès les républicains est venu parler
de sa capacité à porter les couleurs de
son parti pour l'élection présidentielle
à travers son parcours politique
l'expérience de la miss universités 4008
neuf mois face à la rue et fait l'une
des réformes est plus difficile du
quinquennat sarkozy l'ami du budget qui
a géré les finances de la france pendant
la crise des dettes souveraines de la
présidente de région
qui s'est battue qui a conquis une
région et qui la dirige alors que c'est
une région à la fois urbaine et rurale
riches mais aussi très inégalitaire dans
la salle du théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de nombreuses
connaissances de valérie pécresse des
sénatrices des conseillers
départementaux et régionaux ou encore
des maires de commune yvelinoise
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est la seule
qui est sincère ou c'est la plus sincère
avec ses convictions et c'est la seule
qui a montré qu'elle pouvait aller
entraîner
les citoyens sur un sujet pour réformer
la france sans changer d'avis au gré des
sondages c'est quelqu'un qui fait
et c'est vraiment ce que le besoin pays
a besoin aujourd'hui arrêtons les
discours les promesses les jeux les
manipulations de chiffres c'est
quelqu'un de sérieux moi je dirais que
en plus c'est quelqu'un qui fait ce
qu'elle vit mais il y avait aussi des
militants les républicains qui n'ont pas
encore fait leur choix hopla décidé il
voit qu'un ter une
personnalité sans pleurs
et quelqu'un qui est là
je parmi nous
et nos ennemis potentiels face à valérie
pécresse quatre candidats xavier
bertrand michel barnier eric ciotti et
philippe juvin le premier tour du
congrès se tiendra du mercredi 1er au
jeudi 2 décembre avant un second tour du
vendredi 3 au samedi 4 décembre jour où
l'on connaîtra le candidat les
républicains à la présidentielle 2022
ce lundi soir également marlène schiappa
était dans les yvelines la ministre
déléguée à la citoyenneté a répondu à
l'invitation de jean noël barrot une
réunion publique programmée à
vélizy-villacoublay matile de franco
ils étaient environ une centaine à
s'être inscrits pour pouvoir échanger et
poser leurs questions à marlène schiappa
et jean-noël barrot ça faisait un moment
qu'on voulait que marlène schiappa
puisse venir à la rencontre des îles vie
noise et des yvelinois de la 2e
circonscription pour échanger sur les
sujets dont elle a la responsabilité
c'est à dire les sujets de citoyenneté
de laïcité idée sur les sujets sur
lesquels elle a eu des responsabilités
par le passé notamment la question
l'égalité femmes-hommes donc on est on
est très content que cet échange ait pu
avoir lieu plusieurs thématiques autour
de la citoyenneté ont été abordés au
cours de cette réunion publique lundi 15
novembre à vélizy-villacoublay des
sujets comme la laïcité l'intégration
des réfugiés
l'abstention ou encore la protection des
femmes face aux violences fig lassant de
voir le travail de ces policiers
gendarmes et du psychologue qui nous
accompagnent parfois des enfants
l'heure était aussi au bilan pour la
ministre qui a défendu un grand nombre
de réformes et d'action porté par le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron depuis
le début de son quinquennat à cinq mois
de l'élection présidentielle et donc
marlène schiappa sur la question de
l'accueil des afghans sur la question de
la lutte contre le séparatisme la lutte
contre les stupéfiants a pu rendre
compte de l'activité des activités de
son ministère et je trouve que c'est
très bien il s'agissait de la première
réunion publique organisée par le député
suite à la crise sanitaire mais
l'objectif est d'en tenir une tous les
mois
faire gagner l'écologie et la justice
sociale lors de la présidentielle de
2000 22 à gauche des citoyens demande
l'organisation d'une primaire populaire
l'objectif rassembler et désigner un
seul candidat le groupe local de saint
quentin en yvelines s'est réuni ce mardi
devant l'université versailles saint
quentin pour parler de l'initiative les
propos recueillis par mélanie poquet et
bixente mais rien senti stéphane
l'objectif étant de donner de donner en
de donner une chance à ces valeurs là
l'écologie et la justice sociale qui
aujourd'hui sont pas du tout à priorité
du gouvernement actuel c'est pour ça que
j'espère vraiment qu'on ait un autre
gouvernement un autre président en 2022
serait super porteurs de se dire que
pour une fois les les partis politiques
et les candidats mettent de côté leurs
intérêts personnels en retard elle les
intérêts de leur parti face à l'intérêt
qu'ils sont plus grand aujourd'hui de
leur répondra aux différentes crises que
qu'on connaît et d'autres actions lieu
partout en france jusqu'au 19 novembre à
lui est ce qu toujours un nouveau lieu
de vie et des changes pour les étudiants
une surface de 400 m² pour la mezzanine
vauban qui regroupe des espaces de
travail et de convivialité pour les
étudiants mathilde francou s'est rendu à
l'inauguration ce lundi
ce nouveau lieu des changes et de
travail est composé de trois petites
salles isolé réservables en ligne d'une
grande salle de réunion modulables et
d'un petit amphithéâtre ouvert tient
lieu de
que kelly peuvent s'approprier andorran
en dehors des horaires de cours est donc
c'est un lieu ici où ils pourront venir
travailler seul ou à plusieurs mais
également un lieu de convivialité
d'interaction et des espaces de détente
un projet nécessaire surtout après la
crise sanitaire qui a chamboulé le monde
étudiant après ce qu'on a connu c'était
hyper important pour pression de ses
campus de ses composantes ici d'avoir un
lieu de vie un lieu de travail afin de
partager en fait pour faire du un peu de
lien social et puis c'est un lieu qui
est très agréable très agréable un
nouvel espace de travail qui vient
compléter la bibliothèque universitaire
et la maison de l'étudiant il allait à
la bibliothèque de saint quentin
ouais il ya aussi des salles de travail
mais il y en a trop court
il allait à la maison des étudiants eux
hilali sinon ils se réunissaient ce dans
des salles de cours qui était qui était
vide il n'y avait pas de vrai lieu de
vie dédiée de diana coût des travaux
577000 euros auquel l'état a participé à
hauteur de 200 mille euros et la
contribution de vie étudiante et de
campus à hauteur de 246 milles euros
et la fin d'une semaine à saint quentin
en yvelines pour sensibiliser à la
liberté d'expression à travers le monde
après avoir rencontré des élèves depuis
le 8 novembre dernier trois réfugiés
politiques écrivains chanteuse
journalistes ont participé à une table
ronde s'étaient organisés par la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
ce lundi la soirée des écrivains
persécutés emprisonnés et empêcher animé
par nouradine agnel journalistes à
marmite fm retour avec bixente mairie
son site evans est un grand respect à
avoir pour ces gens là est la moindre
des choses c'est de manifester notre
soutien par notre présence organisé pour
la journée des écrivains en prison du
lundi 15 novembre la 11e soirée des
écrivains persécutés emprisonnés et
empêcher se tenait à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines trois
écrivains se sont livrés à une table
ronde pour échanger autour de leur
histoire c'est important pour au nom de
rencontre
les gens ici parce que je veux qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui habitent
la france paris où il ne sait pas que
vraiment qu'est ce qui se passe dans
notre pays c'est important dit physique
et nous les personnes qui sont protégés
pour lui ici en france à proposer toutes
les choses que si on passait chez nous
dans notre pays
nous sommes des personnes qui en
dépendent et ont un parcours on bien
avec des histoires et on a des richesses
pauvreté à notre société intervenante de
la soirée l'artiste musical à marina
tour avaient déjà fui son pays natal la
colombie est en jeunes cette fois c'est
le venezuela qu'elle a quitté en raison
des messages qu'elle véhicule et lors de
ses concerts entre autres le féminisme
et la liberté des jeunes c'est une
dictature et c'est et cédant 0,6 donc et
les personnes qui sont en train de
chercher la liberté d'expression' n'ont
pas la place et cheissoux dans ces
quatre là où venezuela d'evra nef dire
élima lui était condamné dans son pays
pour avoir milité pour le droit
d'étudier en langue kurde j'étais un
présent pour 11 ans 3 mois et donc
pendant mes années présent j'ai essayé
d'écrire un kurde aujourd'hui longue de
kurdes pour le code c'est interdit mais
par exemple il ya une responsable s'il
parlait coeur pour juste et très pour
faire de propaganda aurait celles liées
au troisième intervenant anderson dea
mitchell journalistes haïtiens qui a
suivi plusieurs tentatives d'assassinât
dans son pays pour son émission traitant
de sujets liés à la corruption une
soirée comme point final d'une semaine
de sensibilisation autour de la liberté
d'expression les trois réfugiés
politiques ont rencontré et discuté avec
plus de 400 élèves saint quentinois
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant nouveau
numéro du cetud culture émission en
partie consacré à la programmation du
centre culturel et jean vilar à mali à
marly-le-roi et c'est avec célia agathe
son go belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]